As a developer I quickly got into the habit
of pushing to GitHub multiple times a day.
So, it surprises me when I hear that Operations
teams are tackling their infrastructure automation
with a lot of manual processes. Hey everyone, my
name is Sai Vennam, and today I want to talk about
Ansible. Ansible is an open source infrastructure
automation tool, initially developed by Red Hat
and enables you to tackle kind of all of the
major challenges that come with infrastructure.
It enables you to do so with code, or
in other terms infrastructure as code.
Now Ansible has three major kind of uses and I'll
start with the first one because this is generally
the one that people tend to gravitate to when
they hear infrastructure automation, and that's
the provisioning use case. So the first step of
kind of any infrastructure story, you've got to
have some infrastructure in the first place. So,
let's say that using Ansible we've already spun
up some environment, let's say it's a VPC and my
favorite cloud provider, and within this VPC I've
got three virtual machines. So, we'll say we've
got one, two, and then a third one as well. Now
these set of virtual machines are going to
essentially be our set of hosts. In the Ansible
world, we're going to call this an inventory. So,
it's basically the set of hosts that Ansible can
work against. So, what we're going to call this
is an inventory. Now within this inventory we can
actually create even more sub categorizations and
Ansible calls this patterns. So, let's say these
virtual machines have different, you know,
underlying tasks and use cases and services
that they're going to be running. So, these
first two virtual machines will call them web
because they're going to be used for
web servers, and then this last one
we're going to call this DB because we're going
to run MySql database on it. So, there we go we've
got our infrastructure we've got that provision
kind of step already done, and I want to jump to
the second thing that Ansible is really good at
it's config management. And actually I'd say this
is kind of the main use case that most people
think about when they first start to use Ansible,
and this kind of refers to the ability to
configure your actual infrastructure. So a
simple example would be something like operating
system patches, or maybe making sure a certain
service is running, maybe installing some service
onto a virtual machine. So in our use case today,
let's focus on that, let's focus on how we can
do config management with these virtual machines.
Now one of the key tenets of Ansible is that
it's declarative. Now out there there's kind of
the notion that Ansible can be both declarative as
well as procedural or imperative, and the idea is
that, you know with Ansible you declare what you
want instead of focusing on how it gets there.
But in essence it can also be considered
procedural because the underlying tasks that run
are procedural in nature, but as a user of Ansible
you're taking advantage of the declarative aspect
of it meaning you define what you want rather
than how to get to whatever it is that you need.
Now today, what we want is to be able to run some
tasks against those VMs. Let's say we want to run
some OS patches and then install a programming
language, and then install MySQL. So, what we'll
need is a playbook. So that's what we'll start
with first, we'll create an Ansible playbook
and as the name indicates a playbook is going to
be a book of tasks or a set of of plays rather.
Now our first play we want to run this against all
of our hosts and we want to just run a security
patch, we want to make sure they're all running
the same version of the same operating system. So,
that will be our first play. So a play is going
to be kind of consisting of three main things,
you need a name for that play, you need the host
that it's going to run against, and you need the
actual tasks that will run. Now in this particular
play, let's say that we've got the hosts set to
all because we want to run this against
all the hosts. And as far as the tasks
we'll define some set of tasks like
security patching and that kind of thing.
Now key thing that I want to mention here, Ansible
takes takes advantage of YAML to do its kind of
declarative nature of being able to declare what
you want. So this would this is obviously not
a valid YAML but in the real world you know when
working with Ansible this would be in YAML format.
So that'll be our first play running
against all of the hosts in our inventory.
Now let's let's create some more plays here. Let's
create a play that runs directly against the hosts
for our web servers. So we call that web,
right. And this is going to have a set of tasks,
maybe we need to do something like install Go and
install Python, maybe install some other services
that are specific to our web servers. And finally
we'll create one more play in this playbook,
and for this one we'll set the host to be our
DB, and then for instead of tasks let's talk
about something called roles. Ansible has a
concept of roles which basically enable you to
group together actions that you run multiple
times. So instead of having to define all of
the tasks every single time you can just define
the roles and that will take advantage of you
know the underlying modules and tasks that need
to be run. By the way, a playbook is one way of
grouping together a set of tasks that you need
to run, it's a declarative way of doing it,
but if you really want to keep things
procedural imperative you can actually run
one-off tasks by themselves and do so in a in an
imperative way or a procedural way, but this is
kind of the way you would do a fully declarative
approach to automate a set of tasks against you
know the set of hosts in your inventory. So, this
is our playbook and we want to execute this now.
That's going to bring me to my second tenet of
Ansible and that's the fact that it's agent-less.
Now Ansible is agent-less in in the sense that
like a lot of other infrastructure automation
tools, unlike a lot of other infrastructure
automations, you don't actually need to install an
agent on the VMs that were provisioned. So,
Ansible is able to take advantage of SSH
to actually directly go into those VMs and
run the tasks that it needs to. So, let's
see what that looks like right. So we take our
playbook and as a user we'll execute Ansible, and
Ansible can execute you know and most unix-like
environments, so we'll execute our playbook and
it'll run against our virtual machines and there
we go, we're happy. But here's one thing to think
about. Now chances are we wouldn't be running
Ansible on our local machine, right. At the
end of the day it has to store SSH keys and a
lot of kind of other secure configuration and
you're not really trying to run automation off
your local machine. So there's a capability out
there called AWX, or Ansible tower, which is
the downstream project of the open source AWX,
and that's basically a graphical interface and
set of APIs that enable you to run Ansible and
operationalize it across your organization. So
whether you're using Ansible, or Ansible Tower, a
user will come in execute that playbook and there
we go, we'll have our config management executed.
Now the third aspect that I want to talk about
with Ansible is the fact that it's idempotent.
Now what exactly does that mean? So idempotent refers to an operation that can be
run multiple times without changing beyond the
initial application. In other terms, the first
time I run this operation it should recognize
that the security patches need to be installed,
the services need to be installed, the Python and
Go and MySQL, or whatever needs to be installed
has to be done. The second time I execute that
same playbook it's going to recognize it's already
done it and it's going to say hey nothing needs
to be done. But let's say I come back my second
day and I say oh we need to actually update the
operating system version from you know 1.0 to 1.1,
and we run this same playbook
and Ansible, or Ansible Tower,
and then recognize it and says hey that operating
system has changed but nothing else did it's going
to execute the only action needs to to kind of
resolve that difference. Now one thing to consider
all of these tasks have underlying modules that
power them and you want to make sure make sure
that the modules themselves are programmed in
a way that's idempotent. And this is important
and it kind of brings me to my last point
here is that Ansible is community driven.
That means that if I'm trying to do these things
in a playbook that I kind of outline today
chances are someone out there has already
developed the playbooks, the modules, the tasks,
that I need to actually do those operations. Those
are basically published as collections in what's
called Ansible Galaxy, which is a repository where
developers can kind of contribute their Ansible
kind of modules, or playbooks, or tasks whatever
they might have created in the ecosystem. That's
one of the great things about Ansible is that it's
so community driven that chances are whatever I'll
need to do I'll be able to find in that galaxy,
Ansible Galaxy. The one kind of disclaimer I'll
say, make sure run these operations locally,
make sure they're item potent, make sure
that you know executing them multiple times
responds in a way that's kind of predictable.
So all that being said, we've kind of talked
about how Ansible is a declarative language,
it doesn't require an agent to be able to
execute in these kind of end environments
in these virtual machines. It's idempotent based
on the modules that you're using to enable you to
avoid things like config drift by making sure
that any changes that you make should be done
in your infrastructure automation story,
whether it's playbooks, or roles, or modules.
And then finally, you know you can rest easy
knowing that chances are whatever you need to
automate is available in the community. Now
the third use case I mentioned, there are
three things that you can do with Ansible, it's
going to be app deployment. Now I'm not going to
go into too much detail here today about the app
deployment use case, but the fact is you can use
Ansible to then take it a step further and deploy
your actual web applications and workloads into
the virtual machines, it's also a capability
available by Ansible. I hope this was helpful.
If you like this video or have any comments,
be sure to drop a like or comment below.
Stay tuned and follow us for more videos
like this in the future. Thank you.